supón que los hombres tienen una altura
media de 178 centímetros con una
desviación estándar de 8 centímetros las
mujeres tienen una altura media de 170
centímetros con una desviación estándar
de 6 centímetros las alturas de los
hombres y las mujeres tienen una
distribución normal de forma
independiente elegimos aleatoriamente a
un hombre y a una mujer
cuál es la probabilidad de que la mujer
sea más alta que el hombre los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y piensen en esto
les daré una pista qué tal si definimos
la variable aleatoria h como la altura
de un hombre elegido aleatoriamente
definimos la variable aleatoria m como
la altura de una mujer elegida
aleatoriamente y definimos una tercera
variable aleatoria en términos de estas
dos llamemos a esta nueva variable de
por ser la diferencia d es igual a la
diferencia entre la altura de un hombre
elegido aleatoriamente y la de una mujer
elegida aleatoriamente la variable
aleatoria d es igual a la variable
aleatoria
h menos la variable aleatoria m las
primeras dos variables tienen una
distribución normal nos lo dicen en este
enunciado las alturas de los hombres y
las mujeres tienen una distribución
normal y estamos por conocer que la
diferencia entre variables aleatorias
que tienen una distribución normal
también tendrá una distribución normal
con todo esto que mencionamos cómo
resolverían este problema la
probabilidad de que la mujer sea más
alta que el hombre resolvamos estos
juntos para ayudarnos a visualizar esto
voy a dibujar las curvas de distribución
normal de cada una de las variables
aleatorias la primera es para la
variable h aquí en medio tenemos la
media de h que nos dicen es igual a 178
centímetros suponemos que todo está en
centímetros también sabemos que tiene
una desviación estándar de 8 centímetros
por ejemplo esta es una desviación
estándar por encima de la media y esta
es una desviación estándar por debajo de
la media este punto de aquí tendrá 8
centímetros más que 178 por lo que será
186 y este
a 8 centímetros por debajo de la media
que es 170 centímetros todo esto es para
la variable aleatoria h para la variable
aleatoria m nos dicen que la media dm es
170 centímetros y una desviación
estándar por encima de la media va a ser
de 6 centímetros más que es la
desviación estándar aquí tenemos una
desviación estándar por debajo de la
media menos 6 ahora veamos la diferencia
entre estas dos la variable aleatoria de
pensemos un poco en esto la media de d
va a ser igual a la diferencia entre las
medias de h y de m va a ser igual a la
media de h menos la media de m lo que
será 178 menos 170 lo escribimos 178
menos 170 es igual a 8 centímetros por
lo que esto es 8 cuál será la desviación
estándar debido a que estas dos
variables son independientes aquí nos lo
dicen de forma independiente elegimos
aleatoriamente a un hombre ya una mujer
así que suponiendo que estas dos son
variables independientes
si tomamos la suma o la diferencia entre
ellas la dispersión va a aumentar pero
no vamos solamente a sumar las
desviaciones estándar
lo que hacemos es decir que la varianza
de la diferencia será la suma de estas
dos variantes vamos a escribir lo puedo
escribir varianza con be a r
poner la desviación estándar al cuadrado
la desviación estándar de de nuestra
diferencia al cuadrado que es la
varianza será igual a la varianza de
nuestra variable h más la varianza de
nuestra variable m esto puede parecer
poco intuitivo tendría más sentido si
este signo fueron más pero no importa si
sumamos o restamos si estas son
variables realmente independientes
no importa si sumamos o restamos vamos a
sumar las varianzas esto va a ser igual
a la desviación estándar de h es 8 al
cuadrado que es 64 más la desviación
estándar de m que es 6 al cuadrado lo
que nos da 36 si lo sumamos nos dará 100
y ahora para encontrar la desviación
estándar tenemos
calcular la raíz cuadrada de 100 la raíz
cuadrada de 100 es 10 una desviación
estándar por encima de la media va a ser
18 y una desviación estándar por debajo
de la media va a ser menos 2 ahora si
usando esta distribución podemos
responder a la pregunta cuál es la
probabilidad de que la mujer sea más
alta que el hombre podemos reescribir
esta pregunta como cuál es la
probabilidad de la variable aleatoria de
pensemos cómo definirla qué condiciones
debe cumplir pausa en el vídeo y piensen
en ello la situación en la que la mujer
es más alta que el hombre nos dará aquí
un valor negativo así que tiene que ser
menor a 0
así pues queremos encontrar la
probabilidad de que d sea menor a 0 si
decimos que en nuestra distribución 0 se
encuentra por acá nos interesa encontrar
el área bajo la curva que es menor a
esto hay un par de formas en las que
podemos hacer esto podemos encontrar el
puntaje z para de igual a 0 lo que es
bastante directo
es igual a cero menos nuestra media que
es 8 dividida entre nuestra desviación
estándar que es 10 menos 8 entre 10 es
menos punto 8 en la tabla zeta
buscamos cuál es el área bajo la curva
debajo de z igual a menos punto 8 otra
forma en la que podemos hacer esto es
usar una calculadora gráfica aquí tengo
un emulador dt y 84 en mi computadora
donde tenemos una función de
distribución normal acumulada oprimimos
segundo y podemos usar distribución lo
que despliega varias funciones y vamos a
usar normal
cdf que es la opción número 2 y para el
límite inferior voy a querer infinito
negativo pero las calculadoras no tienen
el valor de infinito negativo pero
podemos poner un número negativo muy
grande que para nuestros propósitos es
equivalente a infinito negativo ponemos
menos 1 por 10 a la potencia 99 ponemos
1 luego oprimimos segundo después la e
mayúscula que indica el exponente y
ponemos 99 este es un número muy negro
para el límite superior borramos esto y
ponemos 0 queremos el área que va desde
menos infinito hasta 0 aquí ponemos la
media que calculamos 8 y la desviación
estándar es 10 regresamos a la pantalla
principal y damos enter pudimos haber
escrito todo esto directamente la
pantalla principal esta función es para
encontrar el área acumulada entre dos
valores de una distribución normal en
este caso entre menos infinito y 0 donde
la media es 8 y la desviación estándar
es 10 damos enter y tenemos
aproximadamente 0 punto 212 lo
escribimos la respuesta a cuál es la
probabilidad de que la mujer sea más
alta que el hombre es aproximadamente 0
punto 212 o 21.2 por ciento un poco
mayor que 1 en 5